they're cooling down eventually you
might be thinking about grabbing lunch
outside or maybe brunch the gramercy in
south in the southwest has many options
jc fernandez is live at dw bistro with
more hey jc what's going on
hey rocky hey kendall yeah the weather
is perfect here we have a dining outside
at the gramercy and dwb show is one of
my favorites bryce is here dalton is
here you've got some new wines tell me
more about your wines so this is our
first wine dinner since coming back from
pandemic and we went out to napa in
april of this year and met the el ellman
brothers and this is a a winery single
vineyard uh for cabs they also do samia
blanc uh they are two brothers who
started just like we are two brothers
who started this they have never been in
the vegas market so they make such small
cases that they've never broken into the
vegas market so they're doing their
first wine dinner in las vegas with us
on wednesday okay and then they'll be
displaying their wine all throughout
vegas so next wednesday your one event
this would be an exclusive event to try
this wine for the first time dalton you
always have great food with some of the
food you have on wednesday well one of
the foods that we're going to have is
our um
amazing caviar collected caviar from
nina from forte it's going to be amazing
we also have our bass cheesecake with
our strawberry preserve
and we're going to have curry lamb
because that's jamaican we love curry
bone in um we're also going to have our
apricot
pork chop
with cabbage it's going to be delicious
okay can i try it a little taste okay a
little bit taste here and we are going
well hold on
bryce one more question
you have your you have your brunch on
sundays tell us more about your brunch
uh i mean it's 12 years of standing in
line having mimosas i i'm jealous um
you know i mean
the chicken and waffles the chilaquiles
the the dj sometimes we have frank
marino here doing drag brunches we do
themes every now and then so check our
website if we dress up again because we
expect our clients to dress
up uh you get into character you're
getting in character this is fantastic i
gotta send it back to the studio but
which one which one should i try
try to wrap dry the red all right guys
i'm gonna send it back to you in the
studio we have more from the gramercy
coming up we have some wine and i'll
send it back to you
talk to you